american student amanda knox has been
described as a satanic diabolical
she-devil at the appeal against her
murder conviction in Italy a lawyer for
the man initially questioned for killing
British student meredith kercher asked
the court whether Amanda Knox is the
mild looking fresh-faced person they saw
in front of them or a woman devoted to
lust drugs and alcohol well journalist
nick pisa brought us this update from
the court in perugia that statement came
from carlo Pacelli who is a representing
Patrick Lumumba he was the congolese bar
owner who was initially named as the
suspect for the murder by Amanda Knox
when she was questioned by police back
in november two thousand seven and she
had told police that she was in the
kitchen where the murder took place and
had covered her is because she
remembered Patrick was murdering
meredith and she covered areas to drown
out the screams and as a result of what
she told police Patrick Lumumba was
arrested and held in custody for two
weeks before eventually being freed when
I bar someone who went to the bar a
customer sell told police that he could
not have been there at the murder of
play at the murder house when it took
place because he was there at his bar
now Carla Pacelli used those colorful
words to describe a man because he is
entitled to make a civil claim and
against Amanda Knox and rocket is less
chouteau asking them the damages for
what he says his client suffered moral
damages also psychological damages
financial damages because of the
besmirching his character that followed
him being named as a as the prime
suspect in that murder now he was at one
point Karlovich le asked her to stick to
the point but he said that he needed to
use this language to indicate to the
court just what sort of person Amanda
Knox was and as as he was making these
statements her her parents were sat to
the side of her just shaking their heads
in in in or as to how their daughter was
being described and he closed his final
arguments by describing her as a
deceitful which as well